hey guys I just filmed the same video
two times in a row
sometimes things just go wrong
ah the video distorted I checked out the
settings I fixed it I formed it again
and then for some reason it distorted
again and my computer Auto upgraded
itself and installed some updates and
then the audio settings was at 100 on
the microphone and everything distorted
again and I'm down here now to get some
coffee
and uh
I just wanted to share this with you
it's like a a pastor who would stand
there and preach his whole sermon and
then go again and then he has to do it
again a third time and it gets tiring so
you know everything here at home here
doesn't happen just smoothly there are
challenges
but I'm going through these challenges
with God that gives me strength wanted
to share that with some of you who might
need this message today
love you guys bye